I'll talk about some of our new cast
it's pretty incredible
we've got John Vega we've got a Oscar
Isaac we have Daisy Ridley and
apparently someone who is legally
required to be in every Disney movie
Lupita Nyong'o uh you guys want to see
him I'll cast on Oscar Daisy I'm the
penis
I know the plaintiff stole was you know
the name Drew Struzan and he's an
amazing artist and he designed all the
posters for the Star Wars movies and
apparently he's designed an exclusive
d23 poster
yeah
yeah yeah I you know I'm gonna just go
in there I think you guys can get one
each I think you
which that is great a free poster is
always cool but the the weird thing for
me is that there's one person in the
poster who's not on stage
I am delighted to be here now with JJ
and this wonderful cast and with Disney
who has supported this effort in in a
really extraordinary way and will
continue to do so I'm I'm quite sure so
it's like it's a great thrill to be here
with you who made this whole thing
happen and I I couldn't be happier thank
you so much
you
you